you know I mean I'm like 11 years old by
the month 175 pounds at 11. yeah 160
something but I'm short though so I'm
fighting I don't know if I'm fighting
because I'm taking them trying to take
something for him that mostly that
happens when you're fighting him and his
family so I'm trying to take some maybe
it's jacket or his watch something I'm
trying to take I'm just I'm trifling
like that back then and then I I was
fighting with him and I don't know if I
snatched this code off but his father
came running down the street and when he
was on the floor his father just came
and he started to try to throw I picked
him up slammed them on the floor
and um the kid jumped on me from behind
yeah you know I kicked the ass but they
kicked my ass too